on clubhouse i feel like i could really
be all
aspects of who i am so i've hosted
parenting rooms i've hosted latino rooms
i've hosted a gay room for lgbt people
clubhouse is for comedy impressions you
could be listening in and one moment
i might be john oliver the host of last
week tonight
then you become jeff goldblum hi hello
yes yes daddy jeff goldblum listen folks
clubhouse is for everyone to get
a little bit of podcast a little bit of
conference
a little bit of twitter and a little bit
of radio
all in one clubhouse everyone this is it
the new audio only social media thing
that everyone is talking about
but even though this is very much about
audio i'm coming to you in video to make
this
a little bit easier to understand
clubhouse is very much
not about video there's no video over
here either
in twitter's clubhouse clone twitter
spaces
both of these are very much about
talking a lot of talking
and listening so that's exactly what i
did
i went inside these apps well literally
right now
to talk and listen to the people
experimenting with this stuff
and to find out if this is all a big
deal or just another passing social
media fad
so let's start with what this is all
about
clubhouse is a platform that facilitates
real-time
audio rooms that enable both
listening like passive listening but
also engagement from the audience
that's alexis gay she's a comedian a
podcaster
and an early adopter of clubhouse who's
amassed over a million followers
the best way to think of this app is
like a big hallway full of different
rooms with virtual stages
walk down okay fine scroll down this
hallway
and you see all the open rooms they're
recommended based on who you follow and
what topics you tell the app you're
interested in
join one and you automatically pop up
and start hearing what's going on inside
you can also make a room of your own you
can just invite a few people or
open the door to everyone which is what
i did with alexis
before i knew it there were over a
thousand people in our room
usually there are only a handful i even
spotted media personality perez hilton
in the audience
and brought him up on stage i think this
is like the real perez hilton i'm not
sure
oh yeah it's per it's definitely yeah
i've seen oh we just raised his hand
should we bring him up the person who
controls the room can bring others up to
talk
when you talk the ring around your
profile photo blinks
and you can mute and unmute your mic
here everyone else is just a listener in
the room
you can tap the hand icon to speak or
ask a question
when the event is over it's over there's
no recording
in fact you get this big warning when
you start screen recording
i got permission to record all the
speakers for this video
twitter spaces work similarly and looks
really similar too
though twitter went with the circle icon
versus the squirkle of
clubhouse so yeah it's totally totally
different
this purple circle here indicates that
there's a space going on right now that
you can join
clubhouse for the time being is iphone
only and invite only
twitter spaces is in testing and will
roll out to more people soon
so that's the app but what's there to
actually listen to
well everything and also kind of nothing
there's a lot of rooms about business
the social media business
the tech business the entertainment
business the business of business
oh and so much crypto we use
clubhouse to spread bitcoin education
and knowledge
and connect with people new to bitcoin
and people who've been in the space for
a long time
corey clipston the ceo of
swannbitcoin.com runs the bitcoin cafe
a group that has multiple rooms that run
monday through friday
20 hours per day in the short term
affecting the market and going in the
direction of the us dollar crashing and
bitcoin you know taking over
and if the crypto talk doesn't put you
to sleep there are lullabies
and so i just got on clubhouse and i was
like you know what
i'm just gonna start playing lullabies
[Music]
again
night at 9 00 pm people show up to a
lullaby club
where axel monsoor performs clubhouse
which periodically changes its app icon
to a different user
just changed the icon to a photo of axel
but why not video and why audio and why
right now well partially coveted 19 and
zoom fatigue
matthew friend a comedian who's gotten
really into the app summed it up
perfectly
kind of like how back in the 50s with
radio when you can kind of listen to
baseball games and that was your only
way of seeing it it's kind of like that
now where you're sort of
able to just listen and imagine and that
brings me to the biggest question i've
had through this whole thing
is this just a passing fad are we gonna
really want to do this when we can go
back to
real live events and comedy shows and
music events and
all of the things we used to do in
person twitter's betting that's not the
case and says it's more than a clubhouse
clone
dantly davis twitter's chief design
officer told me about it during a google
meet call
we couldn't use spaces just yet for this
to set
the record straight we actually started
thinking about
spaces in 2019
and as we are getting ready to ship the
group
version of voices which is spaces as you
see it now clubhouse came to market so
clubhouse gave us validation that other
people were thinking about this
as well after spending time in both of
these
i think social audio is here to stay at
least in some shape or form
but with it brings old and new issues
privacy is a big one clubhouse for
instance is very aggressive about
uploading your contacts to its servers
the company says users will soon be able
to use the app to delete contacts from
its servers
and then there's moderation it's harder
to moderate hate speech and
misinformation
in real time audio but i'm gonna go with
perez on this one
because i may be an old fart i'm gonna
turn 43 next month
but unlike some of my peers or friends
when something new is popping i get
excited about it
i don't roll my eyes and groan like ugh
another app
i've gotta try no i'll try it out and
see what it's all about
plus unlike me for this video you don't
need to do your hair or your makeup or
get some fancy zoom background
to participate in this next wave of
social media fun
or chaos yeah it's it's already pretty
much chaos
i just gotta say that when you do the
howard stern it gets so crazy because it
gets so deep and people are very
confused if it's actually him or not